[Music]
all right many adults need five hours of
sleep or less now this is a myth loud
snoring is annoying but mostly harmless
loud snoring is actually a sign that
there is a blockage in your throat your
brain and body will adapt to Leslie this
is a myth I'm dr. Rebecca Robbins I'm a
postdoctoral research fellow at the
Brigham and Women's Hospital and Harvard
Medical School and I'm dr. David
Rappaport I'm a professor of medicine at
the Icahn School of Medicine at Mount
Sinai and I run the research program in
sleep and we're here today to debunk
some of the most common myths about our
sleep watching TV in bed is a good way
to relax before sleep now this is not
something that we would necessarily
recommend you turn the television on and
if it's close to you that's the source
of bright blue light so bright light is
one of the strongest cues to our
circadian rhythm it kick-starts our body
in our brain to become awake and alert
in the morning it's called a sight
gerbera the strongest input to that
circadian the awake phase of our rhythm
drinking booze before bed will improve
your sleep so this is a very commonly
used tactic for people who have trouble
sleeping and they have a drink it's a
drug it's very much like a sleeping pill
and it is true that it will help you get
to sleep as long as you don't drink too
much one or two drinks perhaps what you
do however is it disrupts the normal
sleep it suppresses REM sleep which is a
normal part of your sleep that comes on
a little while after you go to sleep
typically thirty to sixty minutes later
and then when it comes that the alcohol
has gotten out of your system then the
REM comes back perhaps at the wrong time
perhaps too strong and it disrupts
things and so basically it is not
generally recommended that alcohol be
used as a sleeping pill all right lie in
bed with your eyes closed is almost as
good as sleeping I think that one's
pretty definitely not correct sleep is a
very specific process that your body
goes through the most common myth if you
will that we got rid of in the
scientific field 50 years ago is that
sleep was like you know taking your car
and putting in the garage and turning
off the key and leaving it there and
you come back the next morning and it
just is parked sleep is not like that at
all sleep is a very active process when
you go to sleep you into one stage a
little while later you enter another
stage it gets progressively deeper you
then have the REM sleep and then you
wake up momentarily and that whole cycle
takes an hour to an hour and a half and
then it starts again and it happens
three to five times at a night and if
you disrupt any of that something
happens and the next morning you feel it
you don't feel rested now we don't
understand how that actually happens or
why that happens but we do know it does
happen so when you're lying in bed none
of that is happening if your eyes are
closed and you're not asleep
it just doesn't count next if you can't
sleep you should stay in bed and try to
fall back asleep if you don't fall
asleep we generally recommend that you
not stretch it out by and stress
yourself out by just trying and there's
probably nothing that can prevent sleep
as well as I've got caught asleep I've
got to go to sleep I need to feel your
pulse and your blood pressure going up
so what we try and do when we work with
somebody who has this problem with
insomnia is exactly the opposite of that
we try and tell them relax don't worry
about it stay in bed for a little while
and see what happens but don't try to go
to sleep just relax and if you can't
relax and if you don't go to sleep it's
probably better to get up so that you
don't associate the bed with a stressful
situation all right many adults need
five hours of sleep or less now this is
a myth we have scores of epidemiological
data and data from the Sleep Lab to show
that five hours is not enough for the
vast majority of adults there may be
some individuals that may be due ok on
on six hours but much less than that
really is a myth now you might hear
people brag about this saying you know
oh I do know I get five I'm just fine
but by and large we do see those people
likely making up for lost sleep on the
weekends or
Empowered apps for instance so for the
vast majority of us the recommendation
really is seven seven to eight hours
this is a real problem with their sleep
field has been trying to address and
that is that not sleep
has been perceived as a macho thing it
proves how great you are
proves how manly you are in some cases
sleeping is actually good you should
sort of be proud of the fact that you
sleep - your need your brain and body
will adapt to less sleep sounds like
yours no this is a myth if you see that
just like a good nutrition or a great
healthy diet is so important we
similarly have a diet that we need our
brains and our bodies to be at their
best there are actual formal studies
that have tested how people perform with
lack of sleep and how they think they
are performing and it turns out that we
basically are really lousy at saying how
sleepy we are so you know you feel bad
when you have it or not enough asleep
but you have no idea how bad you are and
your performance keeps deteriorating the
more you don't sleep or restrict your
sleep over multiple days and you think
oh I've settled it I you know I have a
little headache it doesn't really bother
me I'm doing just great and what
actually is happening is you're
performing less and less well on the
various things that we can test
including driving simulators you're
falling asleep for three or four seconds
continuously without knowing it all
right it doesn't matter what time of day
you sleep if you look at our biology we
have inside our brain a clock that clock
is set to say this is a good time to
sleep and then at another time it says
this is a good time to be out sleep is
timed it doesn't just happen and even if
you don't sleep for the whole night
you'll be more and more sleepy all night
long but in the morning you'll get a
second wind and that's because the clock
says up time to be up doesn't matter
that you didn't sleep it's time to be up
as Rebecca said we've gained an
incredible ability to not abide by that
rhythm and the problem is that people
think that they can get away with things
that are biology just won't let us do
nurses have been most studied for this
and firefighters and emergency workers
and people who live on ships they all
pay a price epidemiologically we've
shown higher heart disease and more
tendency to gain weight and a
idea of malfunctions and difficulties as
time goes on you can do it but it's
gonna cost you
exercising within four hours of bedtime
will disturb your sleep we give as
advice is that about an hour before
sleep you want to try and avoid active
kind of things and exercise certainly is
one of them on the other hand there are
people who exercise close to sleep and
do very well so I don't think we should
say you know if you're somebody who
exercises regularly and evening and you
sleep beautifully and you feel rested
the next morning that you should give up
exercise because I think that would be a
bad bit of advice you'll gain weight
you'll lose the toning that you've
gotten so and so forth on the other hand
you haven't been doing it I probably
wouldn't start exercising at night and
if you're having trouble with sleep
that's one of the first things we look
at after drugs like caffeine to try and
get rid of all right remembering your
dreams is a sign of a good night's sleep
I think that there is a huge variation
in how much people remember their dreams
some of it has to do with when you wake
up if you wake up during REM sleep you
almost always will remember dream some
of us don't remember anything at all
about our dreams and it doesn't seem to
harm them but it's not a true thing that
just because you don't remember your
dreams that you're not having good sleep
what tells you you're having good sleep
is how you feel the next day now if
you're waking up with nightmares that
could be a simple sign that maybe your
bedroom is too hot and you need to turn
down the temperature because a hot
bedroom environment unfortunately can
create fragmented sleep and cause you to
wake up often from nightmares now eating
cheese or other food before bed causes
nightmares I don't think I'm aware of
any particular food that will do that to
everybody but it's very clear that being
uncomfortable will precipitate both bad
sleep and waking up and maybe even
nightmares
so imagine somebody with irritable bowel
syndrome who knows that whenever they
eat whatever gluten or or some specific
food spicy foods it upsets their stomach
when they're awake well guess what if
they eat it before they go to sleep
it'll upset their sleep and it may show
up as a nightmare loud snoring is
annoying but mostly harmless loud
snoring is actually a sign that there is
a blockage in your throat the mildest
form of block it just causes vibration
noise if you've ever you know played
sort of you know with a piece of grass
and you blow through it you know that if
you blow through a tube or a structure
that can vibrate it starts to vibrate
and make noise many instruments are
based on exactly that principle you're
creating a vibration by blowing through
a partially blocked tube so snoring is
just that and if that's all it was
it wouldn't be all that bad for you but
unfortunately it usually isn't just by
itself and especially when as they say
on the question loud snoring that kind
of snoring and especially if it's
associated with gasps and snorts and
pauses is actually a sign of a very
common disorder called sleep apnea and
sleep apnea is when that blockage gets a
little bit worse than just causing
vibration and actually blocks the flow
of air in and when that happens you're
actually choking and when that gets
complete we call it an apnea without
breathing from the Greek and your body
defends itself against this blockage by
waking up because everything gets normal
when you wake up the trouble is that
then you go back to sleep and it happens
again and it can happen every 30 to 60
seconds hitting snooze bar is better
than getting up we often hear that
people have 2 3 4 or 5 alarm setup
before they get up in the morning now
the best thing for all of us to do would
actually be just practice leap I gene
and have a consistent bedtime and
actually wake up with an alarm but of
course that's a lot harder in an
actuality
the best thing for us by and large is to
set your alarm clock for the latest time
that you can in the morning to allow for
as much sleep as possible but that will
allow you to go about your daily routine
and get to work on time because if we're
hitting several snooze bars and waiting
I think I believe it's 9 minutes
another nine minutes all of that
incremental sleep is is very rarely that
it's much more fragmented it's a very
light sleep if anything and the majority
of REM sleep is in the morning right
before we wake up so try to protect that
as best you can and set your alarm clock
for the latest possible time you can
simply become a morning person so that
the difference between a morning and
evening person appears to be influenced
by lots of things that are probably
genetic and it's not something you can
just change by training what you can do
is trick your biology into thinking that
you live in Chicago but you work in New
York and that's what blue light does
with some blue light therapy actually
using bright blue light in the morning
can help it shift those true evening
people a little bit earlier it basically
tells you that you're actually in a
different time zone from where you are
and that shifts you a little bit so
that's the approach we use when the
problem is severe and there's a need for
that it's actually shifting when morning
is rather than shifting whether you work
in the morning so you can catch up on
sleep by sleeping in on the weekends now
for the vast majority of us this is a
very common practice this kind of
sleeping in and and unfortunately in our
society we we term it as this luxury to
sleep in and that's because most of us
aren't getting enough sleep during the
work week or adding bricks into our
backpack of sleep debt now what sleeping
and does is it sends a cute or our
circadian rhythm that we're trying to
change time zone so if we extend our
rising time by more than an hour to
three worse four hours into the morning
you might feel better than if you got up
early but that's sleep the next night is
going to be compromised why we call this
social jetlag our body is trying to
adapt if you're a New Yorker you're
physiologically your body is it thinks
you're in London and you're trying to
adjust to that time so you're going to
be fighting your physiology come bedtime
that next night so the best practice is
to keep a consistent bedtime schedule
and try to get as much sleep as you can
now if you do have an excessive
dad and you really need to pay that back
on the weekends the best way without
interrupting your circadian rhythm would
be to do that with a nap in the
afternoon because that's not gonna
change your your body's physiological
circadian rhythm boredom makes you tired
even if you got enough sleep now yes it
is very true that a boring meeting or
lecture especially especially in the
afternoon may be soporific but if you're
in that environment sleep-deprived is a
bellwether sign that you're not getting
enough sleep so when people say you know
all the airport you know the airplane
makes me tired I get into play and I
fall right asleep boredom alone of
course is not a sleep you know inducing
state boredom is a mask is a way of
unmasking your sleep tendency we in fact
use that in testing we put people in
boring situations and see how long it
takes them to fall asleep if they are
fully satisfying their sleep need they
don't fall asleep for at least 20
minutes sleep is so so critical to our
health and our wellness and our
well-being and every night does count in
light of all the things that we've
talked about remember that if it's not
broken don't fix it so do try to
implement some of its strategies or put
some of the strategies to work that
we've talked about today if you find
that you have a problem because at the
end of the day small changes do make a
really big difference especially when it
comes to our sleep